okay I'm not entirely sure if this is
live but if it is welcome this is Eric
Rosen I'm back for another live stream
on leeches so actually if we go back
just to explain for whoever's watching I
can see that there there is no one
watching right now is that true oh
there's two people watching one of them
is me so for the one person out there
who's watching if you uh if you ever get
this position is black the best move is
Knight F6 um I don't know if I can drawn
Arrow but um the idea would be if Knight
takes E5 Queen A5 check and then black
does give up uh the bishop pair but gets
very reasonable development and uh good
center with the two Center
pawns anyway